Gregory: Three times a week,
I wake up very early and start from Paris.
I kept it secret because others might think
that I'm crazy.
Neither my family knew this.
It's like doing a double life.
We are going to an island where I have a farm.
[quiet music]
I started with almost nothing.
It was really hard to make this production area.
You just have to show humility
faced with the elements of nature.
When I collected my first organic potatoes,
I was very happy.
I was worried about the world
which we will leave to the children.
If you want to be healthy and grow,
must have healthy foods.
And after seven years,
we supply more than 500 schools and kindergartens in Paris.
This is my contribution,
to prepare the next generation to change the world.
Gregory is also the founder and executive director of Xooloo,
an app that helps kids learn good digital habits.
Gregory Veret. Organic farmer. Application Developer.
In honor of all application developers around the world.
Share your story #IMakeApps